et nous sommes maintenant en
communication avec un auditeur au canada
il se trouve au nouveau brunswick
il s'agit de donald landry monsieur
landry bonsoir m'avait envoyé il ya
quelques temps une lettre pour être sûr
que quand on parle du nouveau brunswick
et des acadiens que on donne pas
l'impression à cette émission ou un
d'autre que les acadiens ne vive qu'au
nouveau brunswick
oui on pourrait dire acadiens et les
acadiennes et les premiers à pic en
français au canada
les amis c'est ce qu'a établi un
nouvelle écosse actuellement le notre
ancien acadie et la pression quand c'est
eu le temps de léo
kerry le canado alors ont ils ont décidé
de se débarrasser des acadiens et puis
quand il ya eu la déportation comme
expulsé
noumea cette entité de rester à sauver
dans le bois avec l'aide des nouveaux
des autochtones
mêlant 16 jan sauver combien d'eau pour
former d'autres coloris tout au long du
québec ce qui explique que maintenant si
on se promène par exemple ou aux îles de
la madeleine ou encore on va à saint
pierre et miquelon
on va rencontrer les acadiens de saint
pierre et miquelon un territoire
français on va quand même retrouvé là
des acadiens ou des personnes
originaires de lantriac a dit st-pierre
mi-temps surtout saint pierre louis jazz
une grosse concentration d'acadiens on
pourrait dire que c'est un peu que
chacun rivp tête or en dehors de portage
qui ont été déportés chanson we do pays
voisins ou bien qu'arrivé à la serbie
puis bien dans l'histoire dans le procès
les légendes du pic à expulser son
sauvetage au pays en forme et écolo ni
terre-neuve dans un peu et aussi les
présentoirs et parce que gross porte qui
acadienne et pour tout le québec du
québec montréal jean gautheron soit
région d'oka bien vous êtes peut-être la
personne tout indiquée pour m'aider à
répondre à cette question d'un auditeur
français qui veut savoir quel serait une
deux ou trois grandes différences entre
un québécois et un acadien qui veut quoi
j'allais prendre la région du québec
québec et de montréal
l'accent est différente la culture est
différente
je prends un québécois qui vient la
gaspésie la culture est presque parés
nos accents il est presque
et notre culture est presque par une
descendance est presque pareil donc
chanson est quand même assez appareils
prendre le corps étaient plus rares on a
une grosse différence
mais là si je vous demandais de me
donner une expression de l'acadie qu'un
québécois auraient de la difficulté à
comprendre qu'un francophone
ailleurs dans le monde auraient de la
difficulté à comprendre et ce quelque
chose qui vous vient en tête assez
rapidement dans je suis des nouveaux
projets un langage qui s'appelle le
chiac anglais et français
on a beau bruit d'action onglet langage
acadienne je pourrais dire le gros
tracas ce qu'on sait de la stricte dans
ladite j'ai compris le gros camion a
traversé la rue et est tombé dans le
fossé
c est par l'élan de chair qui se
trouvent dans sudes typiquement du
sud-est de vogondy
mais il ya quand même le vieux français
qu'on utilise encore des simples un bon
ok on peut dire je me suis éloigné je me
suis moi y ait tant de gens pensent au
québec me suis informé je me suis moyer
sam au vieux mon français
puis il ya le glossaire acadien qui en
sortie avec et tout les vieux mon
français comme une aide à se dire qu'on
veut dire comparis est en place et il
est ici a dit rich and south et au
québec qui cite oui oui on dirait et
clermont pour avec la paix je portais
succès le pêcheurs répartis sur ok il ya
des bons en coupe
si tu deviens du nord de québec tard au
petit ami de maria devant la misère à
comprendre les acadiens entre eux
oui merci beaucoup donald et puis bonne
chance fait plaisir